your accent is very sexual is it a mix
of things is it astray lien hn8 well I
didn't feel like I have a ex I feel like
what you don't want the accent I'm aware
I sound like a talking sewer cap I'm
aware I just I just wanted to know where
your where your accent what it is
Malaysian Singapore Singapore is a good
place I like Singapore isn't Singapore
if like you throw gum on the further
beat your ass with bamboo bowl can you
obtain you with panda food how
weird is that
yeah that's pretty weird but also if you
throw gum on the floor in any New
Yorkers home they'll be of you as well
so I mean oh yeah yeah Singapore we do
the same thing we just outsource the
ass-kicking to the government welcome to
stupid questions with Krista Stefano I'm
Krista Stefan L this is Ronny Chang from
The Daily Show and he's also got his
show Ronny Chang international student
coming out on the Comedy Central app
August 13th August 13th - good day good
day good day good day that's ice-t
aren't you like a huge star in Australia
I guess I am well here's the first
stupid question do you think Australia's
too far in Jesus hates it I think it is
too far and I think Jesus hates it yeah
there's always I think you push it all
the way
how does much trailer work again it's so
far we can first of all isn't it like 10
years from now yeah it's not the same
time not the tape same timeframe you
know right there it's still Kennedy
still president yeah so I got to tell
you about that ending Oh tell you people
they don't know yet so don't tell yeah
what's your favorite state capital state
capital state capital or for you you
know cuz international student outlet
I'll allow this just for today what's
your favorite international capital I'm
a big capital guy Krissy capitals that
is the capital of Hawaii you've never
been out there I've been out there twice
love it love Hawaii it's like what would
happen if Asian people in charge there
you go yeah you picked the most Asian
Asian capital other than Asia obviously
yeah Hawaii's awesome great weather as
soon as you land it smells like flowers
right everyone's polite as beaches yeah
great I'm a big Pierre South Dakota guy
have you been in yet and if I've never
been no I really never thought New
Jersey he pins this question is really
dumb just answer you watch porn anymore
I never stopped right you never stop the
other continuous thing that I'm you know
you need in between this I'm gonna go
watch some porn I've been goin thoughts
lately just all thoughts
oh just memory apps well not even memory
sometimes I've just been kind of just
getting his own where my mind is blank
and then it just jizz all right yeah
yeah yeah I've been meditating it's very
zen I started the transcendental
meditation and then I noticed like I'm
getting in this meta you know 10 15
minutes in I have a full boner and then
next thing you know yeah I need a napkin
I don't know what it is know that that's
not trances and all that's not that's
glory halls that's yes
I don't even lie to me how great would
it be it should though tell me about
your underwear thank you for asking
yes what I got on right now dude I've
gone through several iterations of this
process okay
first of all good underwear so important
absolutely rated yes shitty underwear
ruins your life absolutely people don't
even know that shitty underwear cuz the
suit you're wearing shitty underwear do
you think that's normal right that pain
isn't normal right feel pain right one
time I thought I had testicular cancer
but it was just I was wearing the wrong
underwear yeah that's all was mine I was
there with nut huggers now my whole
thing long underwear I'm talking wow oh
wow Stu you like a 1920s bathing so yeah
when you get that long on the way never
rides up
yeah and I've seen here I'm you're wrong
I know the way I'm hung and my Lewis law
all the way
I'm wearing with my ankle alright why'd
you have a good time you really did yeah
appreciate a man I want to give you a
gift
stupid questions you get a stupid gift
by thoughtful you so much so your guy
you sell socks like on the website on
Ronny Chang calm so I wanted to give you
socks with my face and name on it
backwards because I didn't realize that
when you send to the sock company they
reverse the image so it's my face but
it's my name is backwards these are
these are something absolutely yeah and
I got my face right there also do you
get this in size 12 what is this yeah
and then you got your socks with your
face on it right once you show us your
socks then glad that flexibility can you
could you it no don't go my eyes just
then you sell my socks
that's why I kind of did it if I'm being
honest with you I didn't do that for you
I did it kind of cross for me so I'd
appreciate some socks yeah put that leg
down
I feel free to put those socks on your
little baby asian feet whenever you want
[Music]